النحل مسؤول عن تلقيح
ثلث جميع المحاصيل في جميع أنحاء العالم ، لكن
طفيليات المبيدات الحشرية وتغير
المناخ تجعل من الصعب على النحل
البقاء على قيد الحياة ويتناقص عدد السكان
مما يؤثر على ما يقرب من عشرين مليار
دولار يساهمون بها في الولايات المتحدة.
في الواقع ، شهد إنتاج المحاصيل في الشتاء
الماضي أعلى خسائر في مستعمرة نحل العسل على
الإطلاق ، لكن شركة لحوم البقر المنخفضة تعتقد
أنها يمكن أن تمنح النحل دفعة
بتركيبة طعام فائقة الجودة ومعبأة بالمغذيات الخاصة يقولون إنها
تحسن أدائهم
ونظام المناعة ، يقول بعض الناس إننا نقوم
بذلك  نقول إننا
نطور نحلًا قويًا وذكيًا
يغذي النحل بالصيغة ويمكنه
العمل لفترة أطول وفي درجات حرارة أكثر برودة
مفيدة لمحاصيل مثل أشجار اللوز هذه
في كاليفورنيا والتي تحتوي على
نوافذ تلقيح قصيرة قريبة جدًا من هنا ،
أجرينا تجربة حيث  نرى أن
نحلنا كان يقوم برحلات جوية أكثر بسبع مرات في
درجات حرارة شديدة البرودة مع عدم وجود
طريقة آلية لمراقبة
أداء النحل ، يقضي فريق تدفق النحل ساعات كل يوم
في التحديق في الأشجار لعد النحل ، ونعرف
عدد الزيارات التي تتطلبها الزهرة
لتطوير ثمار التمرين  حتى الآن ،
تعمل تجاربهم في الأرجنتين على
زيادة غلة المحاصيل بنسبة تصل إلى 90 في المائة
وصنعوا فواكه مثل هذه العنب البري في
ولاية أوريغون 22  أكبر في المائة في الوقت الحالي ،
يعرف النحل فلو أنه لا يمكنه معالجة كل
مشكلة تؤثر على النحل ، لذا فإن
هدفهم في الوقت الحالي هو تحسين ما لدينا بالفعل ،
وهناك الكثير من الأسئلة التي
لا تزال تنتظر إجابات
ونعتقد أن هذه مجرد البداية  من
رحلتنا أو التلقيح الذي تم
التقليل من شأنه من قبل الصناعة الزراعية